des élections législatives sous haute
tension ce dimanche en albanie le
premier ministre socialiste edi rama
brigue un troisième mandat
il fait face à la forte opposition qui
rassemble le parti démocratique de
l'ouzoum bacha et une dizaine d'autres
formations
leur objectif l'évincer du pouvoir où il
se maintient depuis huit ans et intégrer
l'union européenne quatre années de plus
comme les huit passés sont inacceptables
pour les albanais ceux qui veulent que
le pays intègre l'union européenne
savent que ça ne pourra se réaliser
qu'en votant pour le changement
accusé de dérive autoritaire après avoir
obtenu la majorité en 2017 et dirhams a
dit vouloir poursuivre le travail entamé
renforcer les institutions et les
investissements et promouvoir le
tourisme ou à des sciences est
importante bien sûr parce que il faut il
faut prendre une grande décision pour
continuer à marcher beaucoup donné à
monter pour ne pas faire de panneaux et
alinéa a fait beaucoup il ya beaucoup à
faire mais merci beaucoup a pas sur tous
les chantiers qu'on a ouvert de la
justice dans la validation d'un simple
de la santé les infrastructures projet
ne porte le site
mais les promesses non tenues de ses
précédents mandats sème le doute au sein
de l'électorat
à cela s'ajoutent les nombreuses
tensions entre sa formation et
l'opposition mercredi non loin de la
capitale tirana
une personne a été tuée par balles et
quatre autres ont été blessés dont un
membre des forces de l'ordre suite à des
affrontements entre militants politiques
raison de ces débordements des soupçons
de fraude et de corruption impliquant le
vol de données personnelles de près d'un
million d'électeurs
un scandale qui accentue l'amertume de
la population envers la classe politique
je n'ai pas envie d'émigrer de quitter
mon pays je veux contribuer ici en
albanie à améliorer notre vie à
redresser notre économie améliorer la
politique dans le pays
car la politique actuelle a tellement
nuit au pays c'est bien la démocratie je
n'ai pas de reproches à l'égard de la
démocratie mais j'en ai à l'égard de la
classe politique qui ne se bat que pour
ses propres intérêts depuis la fin du
communisme en 1990 les élections en
albanie sont régulièrement marquées par
des débordements et des contestations
ces législatives surviennent après que
des parlementaires de l'opposition ont
démissionné puis boycotté les dernières
élections municipales l'opposition qui
tente de fédérer la population pour
faire chuter d'hier a mis sous l'oeil
vigilant de la communauté internationale